8 mars journée de la femme une
célébration qui s'est poursuivie
jusqu'au 9 mars dans les jardins de la
villa du département les associations
féminines de l'île étaient conviés pour
un moment de rencontre et de fête de la
danse du chant mais aussi divers stands
de présentation du savoir faire des
femmes de la couture associatives ou de
la couture et des modèles de créateurs
il y en avait pour tous les goûts maria
obtenu le premier prix du concours de
meilleur créateur du 6e salon de la mode
en 2015
organiser la décision' salon de
- et
c'est là tu aimes c'est le petit singe
est très sage et c'est une
qu'on cesse et ulf tissus naturels
du côté de l'association d'hélène
artistes en action il s'agit avant tout
de faire de la récupération de
transformer mais aussi de mettre la
culture à la portée du plus grand nombre
de femmes fait des actions en ce sens
tous les mercredis de tous les mercredis
de 8h30 à 12h on apprend tout public à
coude parce que ce que si sa
personnalité ou bien une initiation à la
couture p1 pas et viennent elle vient
pour deux
afrojack ou de chez nous artistes en
action est basée à sainte marie tout
comme l'association lève la tête marien
qui permet aussi à des femmes de se
retrouver d'apprendre la couture des
femmes venues de tous les horizons
parce que tu as raison c'est un
métissage donc le fait que tout le monde
que tout le monde y retrouve doublement
des récents billets change tout céline
préside l'association à matane le tissu
ethnique devient sont ses doigts issus
de ses adhérents de beaux costumes
traditionnels ou encore de jolies pagne
du bois nos enfants plus en plus on perd
le et autres créatures à douala
tu es bien social pour amener les
enfants pouvaient connaître les
traditionnels et notre grammaire ou bien
de beaux habits qui s'accorde forcément
avec de beaux bijoux la création de
colliers bagues bracelets c'est le
domaine de noëlla elle ne fait pas
partie d'une association mais elle veut
valoriser le savoir faire des femmes
un épais que des créations de bijoux
fantaisie
accessible à tout le monde les hommes
n'étaient pas oubliés pour cette journée
de la femme avec la coopérative
carrefour de l'océan indien
c'est le coco qui valorise et de
tressage tradition c'est strahl et ont
saigné aux plus jeunes dans la
coopérative on est intéressés comment
une couveuse le sait puisqu'il propose
par exemple les jus les moins de 18 ans
et les demandeurs d'emploi
de longue durée ou machin on est tenté
de faire une offre de formation
professionnelle les élus du conseil
départemental et du conseil régional
étaient également présents cette journée
c'est vraiment un m'as dire un élément
est un point important pour les femmes
de se faire entendre dans à travers de
ces événements culturels mais aussi dans
la politique dans nos sociétés de se
faire entendre donc c'est très très
important de se mettre en avant dans ce
type d'événement
oui bien sûr qu'il faut promouvoir la
part de la femme dans l'art au général
et aujourd'hui je peux le voir que dans
cette villa du département il ya
plusieurs expositions qui ont été
réalisés par des femmes qui en plus ne
sont pas forcément connu une journée qui
permet de comprendre et de voir que les
femmes de la réunion sont debout et
combien prendre la place qu'elle mérite
dans notre société